this is session six of the foundations
of finance module and in this session
I'd like to bring together two concepts
we've already talked about cash flows
and discount rates into a single number
the time value of money you've all heard
the saying right at the start of every
finance class you're told a dollar today
is worth more than a dollar a year from
now and depending where else you're in
the world of peso today I repeat today
the question is why and there are three
reasons why a dollar today is worth more
than a dollar you're ten years 20 years
from now the first is human beings for
whatever reason prefer cut present
consumption to future consumption so to
get you to give up present consumption
for future consumption assuming you're
lending stuff out I have to offer you
some compensation
that's called a real interest rate but
that's just a fancy way of saying you
know you've got to give people something
to give a present consumption the second
is inflation which the dollar today
might buy a lot more than a dollar
you're from now and that difference is
going to widen depending on the
inflation rate so higher inflation
becomes the the more the difference will
be between getting a dollar today at a
dollar you're from now and the third is
uncertainty the dollar today I can
collect from your hand but a dollar a
year from now I'm dependent on you
showing up and giving me the dollar and
the more uncertain I feel about that the
less value I would attach the dollar so
the preference for current consumption
inflation and uncertainty and as a
preference increases the time value of
money will go up as expected inflation
increases the time value effect is going
to be greater and the greater the
uncertainty the greater the time value
effect on money so let's bring this
together into a very simple process the
the mechanics of time value of money a
bit around discounting or compounding
discounting reflects effectively
bringing future cash flows back to today
and compounding reflects the fact that
you taking today's cash flows into the
future and the discount rate becomes the
mechanism I use to bring in all three
factors we talked about so holding all
its constant the greater the preference
for current consumption the higher the
discount
it's gonna be the greater the inflation
rate the higher the discount rate and
the greater the uncertainty the higher
the discount rate now that said you can
already see why currencies matter when
you talk about cash flows the value
offer dollar today relative to dollar a
year from now would reflect the
inflation rate of the dollar but the
value of an Argentine peso today and a
peso yo from now will reflect the
inflation rate in the peso currencies
matter when it comes to discount rates
because depending on the inflation rate
in that currency your discount rate will
be higher or lower and this is something
we're going to come back and deal with
more tangibly later in both the
corporate finance and evaluation classes
the discount rate is also an opportunity
cost an opportunity cost in what sense
when you use a discount rate a
discounted cash flow you're also telling
me indirectly or directly that you can
make that rate of return on an
investment of equivalent risk out there
in the marketplace so when you go
looking for discount rates it's not
about what you would like to make on an
investment that drives it it's what you
can make on the next best investment of
equivalent risk so discounting brings
future cash flows back to today
compounding converts today's cash flows
into future cash flows so let's talk
about some very simple present value
principles and obvious ones the first is
if you gave me an investment with cash
flows every year for the next 15 years I
kind of add up those cash flows and give
you any kind of answer because cash
flows at different points in time on
different types of cash flows so cash
flows have to be brought back to the
same point in time that can be either
today or five years from now but as long
as you bring the cash flow the same
point in time you can aggregate them you
can subtract them you can you can net
them up the second is a good investment
rule whether it's in corporate finance
as a capital budgeting rule or in
valuation as an investment rule should
be based not only on how much you will
get in cash flows from the investment
but when you get those cash flows that's
a discounting a time value story so
let's talk about the mechanics of
converting future cash flows in today
one of the one of the contraptions that
is useful in making this adjustment is
what I call a time line sounds fancy
when the timeline here's what you do you
draw time as a line that's why it's
called a timeline then you show me what
you will get as cash flows in each point
in time so your for instance is a
timeline of cash flows of a hundred
dollars in cash flows each year at the
end of each year for the next four years
you're already going to see that when we
talk about cash flows nearing a year I
need to specify where in the year you
get those cash flows the start of the
year the middle of the year the end of
the year or all through the year in this
case these are a hundred dollars in cash
flows each year at the end of the next
four years
that's called an annuity and that will
let me then use the mechanism I have
converting annuities into present value
so with that set up let's talk about the
five types of cash flows that you might
have to deal with you know in fact every
cash flow in Finance I'm gonna argue
some combination of these five types of
cash flows the first is a simple cash
flow what's a simple cash flow I offer
to pay you ten million dollars ten years
from now that's a single cash flow in
the future simple cash flow then we're
going to talk about annuities annuities
are constant cash flows that occur at
regular intervals a hundred dollars here
every year for the next five years is an
annuity sixty dollars a month every
month for the next 24 months is an
annuity the third is a growing annuity
that's a little more daunting but here's
what the growing annuity would look like
a hundred dollars growing at five
percent a year every year for the next
25 years so next I get a hundred and
five the year after I get a hundred
eleven and a five percent growth rate
every year for the next twenty five
years
that's called a growing annuity and then
you get to two measures of cash flows
that are truly mind-blowing the first is
a perpetuity a cash flow constant cash
flow regular intervals for the rest of
eternity forever
that's a perpetuity a hundred dollars
every year forever the second is a
growing perpetuity a hundred dollars
growing at 2% a year every year forever
is a growing perpetuity I'm going to
talk about present value equations that
work with each of these cash flows and
as I talk about them you're probably
gonna wonder why I'm wasting my time
because you have a present value
function in your calculator and it's
true many people no longer use these
equations to compute present values
because it's already
later but I would suggest that you try
these equations at least once or twice
to see what's behind that PV button on
your calculator so let's start with a
simple cash flow you tell me you're
gonna pay to pay me 10 million 10 years
from now you ask me how much is it worth
today here's what I need to do I'll take
the 10 million and I'll discount it back
to today at whatever your rate of return
is whatever discount rate yeah so let's
assume that your discount rate is 8%
that includes your payment for president
for giving up current consumption you're
dealing with inflation and and risk
they're all in there I will take the 10
million and now we'll divide by 1.08
that's the 8% convert into it into it
into a 1 plus R raised to the power 10
what I get is a present value will be
well below 10 million if I want to take
10 million today and move it into the
future I will do the reverse I would
take the 10 million and multiply by 1.08
raised to power 10 as simple as that
let's move on to something about cash
flows that we talk about all the time
but we really don't grasp we talk about
the power of compounding and discounting
but until you actually see the numbers
I'm gonna have argue that his role
really will not capture that powerful
may give you an example you have a
hundred million dollars in revenues
right now let's assume you project out a
growth rate of 50 percent of that
hundred million that's gonna be that'll
mean that your revenues will go from a
hundred to one hundred and fifty million
eminently doable right then you continue
to use 50 percent the year after now
your revenues have to go from 150
million to 225 million a 75 million
dollar increase if you keep the revenues
at 50 percent you're gonna see the
compounding effect very quickly start to
make your number a really big number the
reason I bring this up is when we get to
valuation and use spreadsheets value
companies you are often going to use
growth rates in percent and if you're
not careful your revenues your earnings
or whatever number you grow at that rate
can very quickly become an explosive
number we'll come back and deal with it
but be aware that compounding is a very
real factor conversely when you're
projecting a value 10 years out which is
often what you do in valuation when you
estimate the value of a company 10 years
out and you
get back to today don't be surprised to
see a big loss in value a hundred
billion dollar terminal value at the end
of your tenth today might be worth only
thirty-five billion so sometimes working
with the numbers will get a bit give you
a better sense of the effect of
compounding and discounting here's the
other feature about discount rates that
we sometimes miss often for ease of use
we act like cash flows come in at the
end of every year the reason I say for
ease of use so you're in a business you
don't sell all your stuff at December
31st of every year you sell it through
the course of the year so we for ease of
use we act like cash flows happen once a
year and the discount rate is an annual
ring but to the extent that those cash
flows might be monthly cash flow so
instead of having a hundred and twenty
million dollars at the end of the year
let's say you made 10 million every year
for the next ten years you are in effect
going to see the freedom you see how
much compounding matters if you do it
more frequently I'll give you a very
simple example to show you how the
compounding effect can change the
observed interest rate on a loan or an
investment let's assume you have a ten
percent annual interest rate you
compound only once at the end of every
year you're on a ten percent rate of
return if you compound twice a year
semi-annually and let's say I just
divide the 10 percent and give you a
five percent interest rate in the first
six months and a five percent a second
six months I will actually make ten
point one two five percent you're saying
why because the money I make in the
first six months will now earn money in
the second six months of power of
compounding if I compound every month in
other words I take the 10 percent and
divide by 12 and I give you that monthly
rate every month for the next 12 months
the 10 percent becomes ten point four
seven percent effect at the limit if I
compound continuously and this one of
those don't sell those button on your
calculator might never use it's called
the exponential button you will actually
get the limiting case which is the ten
point five one seven one percent
interest rate if you compound
continuously so the frequency of
compounding matters and that is
something to think about is when you use
annual cash flows you are in fact making
this assumption that cash flows happen
only once you're in the rate using is an
annual interest rate let's move on to
annuities and
nobody as I described it is a constant
cash flow that occurs at regular
intervals so a is the annuity of an
annuity which is fixed at a and every
year for the next four years you get a
you got an annuity the present value of
an annuity can be computed using an
equation as I said most people don't use
these equations anymore because you use
the payment button in the calculator but
this is what's going on behind the
payment button for a cash flow for an
annuity that happens at the end of every
year notice why that matters because it
affects the present value the present
value is the annuity to 10 million 100
million that you get times 1 minus 1
plus R raised to the power n so notice
all the things that come and reflect you
discard rate I mean it looks complex but
you can program this and you can do this
or if you have a scientific calculator
to do it on your own I'll be quite
honest I actually still use these
present value functions rather than the
payment button in your calculator that
my sister if like my age I don't trust
my calculator and give me the right
answer so you told me that your cash
through your annuity is $1,000 CR every
year for the next 5 years yes the
present value the thousand is the
annuity the 10% is the discount rate
notice it shows up as point 1 home what
I get is a present value is three
thousand seven ninety-one value you're
saying how do I know that's the right
number try this out take each cashflow
thousand year one thousand discount each
one separately add them all up you
should get exactly the same answer
present values are additive you can
always check your answer so that's an
annuity let's talk about growing
annuities a growing annuity as I said is
a is an annuity grows at a constant rate
for a particular period 10 years 20
years 25 years again to compute the
present value growing annuity you can do
it the long way you could take each of
these cash flows and discount it back to
today but let's say you're in a hurry
you want to do it in one step the
present value of a growing annuity can
be written just like the present value
of an annuity as an equation and notice
the new variable that's popped up in the
equation the growth rate is now part of
the game
your first cash flow next year's cash
flow would reflect the growth over the
first year so that's 8 times 1 plus G
and inside the brackets you see both the
growth rate at the discard rate when you
have a growing annuity the growth rate
can actually be
higher than the discount rate and you're
still gonna be okay so how can I be okay
G is greater than or that denominator is
going to be negative when G is greater
than are you numerator will also be
negative this equation will work for any
growth rate as long as it's a finite
growth rate so if you have a cashflow
growing at 25% a year for the next five
years and your discount rate is 10% try
it out again check your answer by
discounting each cashflow separately
back the only the only scenario it will
not work as G's equal to RS and what
what do I do that G's equaled are they
cancel out so we have $100 growing at
10% a year for the next five years in
your discount rate is 10% the present
value is going to be five times a
hundred five hundred you don't even need
to go through this calculation now let's
talk about perpetuity so as I said it's
mind-boggling because none of us is
going to be around forever but if you
have a cash flow that is fixed and it's
going to be there forever
a hundred dollars each year forever the
present value of a perpetuity is that
hundred dollars divided by the discount
rate so your discount rate is 8 percent
a hundred divided by 0.08 gives me
$1,250 that's the present value of a
perpetuity you see what's the intuition
if you take that 1,000 250 and put it in
a bank and the bank paid you 8 percent
every year think of what you're going to
get to the rest of it earning eight
percent of 1000 250 is a hundred there
you go you can check your answer again
and finally if you think about mind
boggling here's an even more
mind-boggling concept a cash flow
growing at a constant rate forever $100
growing at 2% a year forever here the
present value of a growing perpetuity is
the expected cash flow one year out you
always have to do that in present values
so 100 and become a hundred and two
divided by the difference with the
discount rate and the growth rate are
minus G this is one of the most used and
misused equations in corporate finance
and valuation you're going to see the
see me use this later in my valuation
class to get terminal value in my
corporate finance class to get the end
value for a project and I'm going to
introduce some rules that go with this
equation that will keep it from from
running away from you because it can
very easily get out of control but in
summary those are the only five types of
cash flows you will ever run into and
knowing the mechanics
computing the present value the cash
flows will stand you in good stead